airports a lot busier this thanksgiving
two of mccarron's large parking garages
are already full that's a sign more of
us are traveling despite the pandemic
bianca holman has maybe a solution if
you're traveling or maybe driving to
your flight today good
afternoon well terminal one garage and
then also terminal three economy lot
both are full so airport officials
recommend an alternate lodge such as the
terminal three garage for long term
parking or the terminal one economy lot
and you have to be aware that some of
those lots require shuttle service so
again you're going to have to add some
extra time if you plan to drive here but
your best bet you guys is to of course
get someone to drop you off or take a
cab or an uber
all was quiet at the airport during the
early morning hours but as the clock
struck 6 30 passengers arriving and
leaving began pouring in we asked these
travelers from sacramento why they chose
the first flight out it's like we caught
an early flight because we didn't want
to catch a bunch of people and traffic
and everything i was just telling i'm
surprised the airport's this empty but
it's early it was kind of hard to wake
up or that early in the morning but it
was worth it i'm excited to be here to
ensure a quick boarding rachel mendoza
says she chose to only use a carry-on
and signed up for tsa pre-check when it
comes to getting through airport
security officials suggest if you want
to travel with your thanksgiving
favorites like turkey mac and cheese or
even pie remember the 3-1-1 rule any
items over 3.4 ounces must go in a
checked bag we also met these houston
travelers ready to celebrate the holiday
and a birthday and being with my friends
because we're all coming from different
places so just for us to get together
again and to prevent any frustrations
for passengers they offer this advice
make sure that you have enough time to
get to the airport and just have
everything you need ready to go so you
don't have to make any last minute trips
back home
and you can just go through the airport
smoothly
[Music]
great reminders there so if you're
planning on traveling on sunday that's
another busy day for holiday travel
experts recommend if you haven't already
booked your flight try traveling back on
monday or tuesday you may have an easier
time getting back home then and of
course we've got some more helpful tips
on our website 8newsnow.com bianca
holmen live local now